اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يواصل قصف منازل ومواقع في غزه حيث ارتفع
عدد الشهداء الى اكثر من 30 شخصا منذ بدء
العدوان وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه تستمر
في اطلاق الصواريخ على ضواحي القدس وغلاف
غزه ما اجبر القياده الاسرائيليه على
تمديد حاله الطوارئ هناك حتى يوم السبت
نتنياهو ينهي مشاورات امنيه بشان التطورات
في غزه ويعلق بالقول انهم مستمرون في
عمليتهم والاذاعه الاسرائيليه تقول ان تل
ابيب ابلغت مصر بوقف محادثات وقف اطلاق
النار في حين يقول قيادي في غرفه العمليات
المشتركه للجزيره انهم ادخلوا تكتيكا
الاستنزاف والتحكم الصامت ومفاجاه
الاحتلال بالمعركه وان فصائل المقاومه تدق
عمق الكيان وقد قلبت نتائج المعركه
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع يوقعان على
اعلان مبادئ في مدينه جده بالتعاون مع
السعوديه والولايات المتحده حيث اتفق
الطرفان على الامتناع عن شن اي هجوم يضر
بالمدنيين وعلى احترام وحده السودان
والالتزام بسيادته والعمل لمصلحه
السودانيين
صندوق النقد الدولي يحذر الولايات المتحده
بقوله ان تخلف واشنطن عن سداد ديونها
سيكون له تداعيات خطيره للغايه على
الاقتصاد الامريكي والعالمي مفيدا انه
يتعين عليها توخي الحذر بشان نقاط الضعف
الجديده في قطاعها المصرفي في ظل الارتفاع
الكبير في اسعار الفائده الى اللقاء